[MUSIC PLAYING]
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY:
Hi, everyone.
Good morning!
Thank you all for joining us for
our talk on OpenThread today.
We are very excited to be here.
And we hope this session will
be very useful to you all.
My name is Vaas Krishnamurthy.
I'm an embedded software
engineer at Nest.
JONATHAN HUI: And I'm Jonathan
Hui, Principal Software
Engineer leading the OpenThread
effort across Nest in Google.
In this session, we
will introduce to you
Thread, a low power
mesh networking
protocol for connecting
your IoT devices,
OpenThread an open source
implementation of that Thread
protocol, and how
you as developers
can start using OpenThread to
build connected IoT devices.
Now, Thread's history
starts at Nest
where our primary focus was to
build products and solutions
that keep you comfortable
while reducing your energy
consumption, as well as
improving the security
and safety of you and your home.
Now, in order to
achieve that vision,
we wanted our products to be
able to communicate directly
with each other,
with cloud services,
and directly with the end
user via their mobile devices.
And so we went looking for our
connectivity technology that
could satisfy those needs.
And in doing so, we sent out
a number of requirements.
The first was that it had to
support the internet protocol
or IP, because we wanted to
build solutions that support
a single application
layer communicating
across multiple
link technologies
such a cellular and Wi-Fi.
It needed to be
scalable, because we
wanted to build networks
that had hundreds of nodes.
It needed to be resilient,
because we wanted
to support safety and security
applications where devices can
communicate, even
when devices fail
or when mains power is lost.
It needed to be low
power, because we wanted
battery powered devices
to last for years
on very small batteries.
And of course, it
needed to be secure.
But as we went looking for
an existing connectivity
technology, we
actually could not
find a single technology
that satisfied
all of those requirements.
And furthermore,
as we were talking
with others in the industry, we
found that many others actually
shared the same concern.
So in July of 2014, Nest, along
with those other companies,
started the Thread Group.
The Thread Group is a
nonprofit organization
with more than 100
member companies
from around the world.
And the Thread Group is
responsible for defining
and maintaining the Thread
protocol specification.
It is a market education group
promoting the use of Thread
in connected products.
And it ensures a
great user experience
through a rigorous
and meaningful product
certification program.
So that was a bit about
the history of Thread.
Now I would like to give you
some of the technical details
of Thread.
In short, Thread is an open
IP-based secure and mesh
networking protocol
for IoT devices.
Now, while Thread is
a new link technology,
its design utilizes existing
technologies wherever possible.
At the radio layer
it uses IEEE 802.15.4
It's the same radio that
ZigBee uses and has been
using for the past 15 years.
And using an existing widely
deployed radio technology
allows Thread products to
achieve a fast time to market
as well as leverage
existing economies of scale
to deliver low-cost solutions.
At the network layer, Thread
uses existing IETF standards
for transporting the internet
protocol version 6 or IPV6
over 802.15.4 radios, a
technology called 6LoWPAN.
Now, Thread's support for
IP is a key differentiator.
Most existing low power
technologies do not support IP.
And so why is IP so powerful?
Well, for Nest, it means
that we could build solutions
that utilize a number of linked
technologies such as Wi-Fi,
cellular, and Thread, and have
all those devices communicating
securely end to end with a
single application layer,
and not have to build
application protocol
translators in between.
And at the same time,
it means that we
could have a single
network supporting
multiple applications
simultaneously.
IP makes it easy to
deploy new applications,
because you don't have to worry
about application protocol
translators in the middle.
And that was a key reason for
the success of the internet
and its rapid growth.
And Thread extends that benefit
to low power IoT devices.
So Thread operates
as a scalable mesh.
Thread supports up
to 32 routers that
are responsible for forwarding
packets throughout the network.
At the same time, each router
is capable of attaching 511 end
devices.
As a result, Thread
can easily scale up
to hundreds of nodes
in a single network.
Now, Threats self-selects
the set of routers and scales
gracefully to different
network needs.
All devices initially
attach as an end device.
But when additional
connectivity is needed,
a Thread device may promote
itself to become a router.
However, when a
router does determine
that its connectivity is
redundant or unnecessary,
a Thread router can demote
itself back to an end device.
So Thread is resilient.
Thread routers perform
a dynamic shortest path
any to any routing protocol.
If you're familiar
with routing protocols,
it is in the class of proactive
distance-vector routing
similar to RIP.
In short, it means that each
router maintains and advertises
the best next hop towards every
other router in the Thread
network.
This dynamic routing
protocol not only
allows Thread devices to
efficiently forward packets
throughout the
network, but it also
allows Thread to
dynamically react
to node failures and
radio connectivity loss.
Now, Thread's resilience
extends beyond the mesh
when communicating
with devices that
are outside Thread's network.
Thread supports
multiple border routers
operating simultaneously,
providing multiple paths
into and out of a network.
Most other technologies rely on
a single hub or a coordinator
for external connectivity
that represents
a single point of failure.
But that's largely
because those protocols
require a get stateful
application gateway in between
to connect that network
to other networks.
But with Thread, you truly have
no single point of failure,
whether that means
you're communicating
with other devices
on the mesh network
or devices off of
the mesh network.
So Thread is low power.
Compared to Wi-Fi,
the 802.15.4 radio
itself consumes about 1/10 the
power in active receive mode.
Now, when you combine
that with the fact
that Thread can sleep end
devices the vast majority
of time, means that Thread
devices could operate for years
on very small batteries.
Now, Thread is also secure.
Thread protects all data
traffic at the link layer
using AES-128 encryption
and authentication
with replay protection.
And unlike other
existing technologies,
security is mandatory in Thread.
There is no way
or option for you
to deploy a Thread network
with security disabled.
What that also means is Thread
had to solve the secure device
commissioning problem in
a very user-friendly way.
Via mobile device,
they open a mobile app,
and discover Thread
border routers
on their network using NDNS.
They then establish a secure
connection with that border
router, and then go over
with their mobile device
and scan the QR code of the
device that they want to join,
and obtain a short pairing code.
The mobile device then
establishes a secure DTLS
session to authenticate
the joining device
and securely provide
the credentials.
In fact, if you've used
a Nest product today,
you'll find this process
is very similar to what
you've experienced.
It really is very simple
and intuitive for the user.
And you'll get to
see a demo of that
in a bit later in the session.
So in summary, Thread supports
all of the design requirements
that we set out
in the beginning.
It supports IP for secure
end-to-end communication
without application gateways.
It supports hundreds of
devices in a single network.
It has no single
point of failure.
It supports lifetime in years
when operating on batteries.
And it has mandatory security
with a very user-friendly
commissioning process.
We started that effort in 2014.
Four years later, we
believe Thread is still
the only communication
protocol that satisfies
all of those requirements.
Now, two years ago
here at I/O, we
launched the OpenThread project.
OpenThread is an open source
implementation of Thread.
And it is the same
implementation
that we use in Nest
products today.
And the goal of
OpenThread is really
to make the same
technology that we
use in Nest products
more broadly available
to developers, and
that means you.
So OpenThread is an open
community-based project,
and it's hosted on GitHub.
All development is
done in the open.
Every commit goes through
a public pull request
where anyone can
comment on and review.
And anybody can make
their own contributions
by submitting issues or
pull requests themselves.
OpenThread is also
licensed under BSD-3.
And since its launch two
years ago, OpenThread
has seen widespread adoption.
OpenThread has been ported to
about 10 different 802.15.4
radios.
And you can find example drivers
for those radios on GitHub.
Furthermore, many of
the silicon providers
provide direct
commercial support
of OpenThread running on their
silicon and in their SDK.
So if you're already working
with a favorite silicon
vendor of yours, I
encourage you to reach out
to them regarding
support for OpenThread.
An OpenThread is also
seeing strong adoption
by IoT platforms--
of course, Android
Things, but also
Particle, runtime, and Zephyr.
Though in addition to the
core thread implementation,
there are a few other
sub-projects that I do
want to mention.
The first is wpandtund,
a user space network
interface driver for Linux.
Remember that Thread
supports the same IP
technology that drives every
internet connected device.
And with wpandtund, you can
present a Thread network
as a standard network
interface of Linux,
which means you can
use the same socket
APIs that you're used to using
to communicate with Thread
devices.
OpenThread also has a
border router sub-project.
And it builds on wpandtund to
provide a quick and easy method
for you to connect
your OpenThread devices
to ethernet or Wi-Fi networks.
And you can do that using
Raspberry Pi or BeagleBone
Black.
And all of the source code
is available on GitHub.
So as I mentioned, OpenThread
is shipping in Nest products
today.
And what that means for
you is that you also
get to take advantage
of all of the hard work
that we put into making
OpenThread work really well
in end consumer products.
So let me tell you a little
bit about how OpenThread really
enables Nest products.
The Nest Detect is a wireless
open-close sensor for things
like windows and doors.
It's also a motion sensor.
And it communicates
only via Thread.
And it does so as a
sleepy end device,
allowing its radio and
processor to sleep more than 99%
of the time.
But when it does detect an
event such as opening a door,
it can quickly wake up,
communicate that event,
and set off the alarm.
And by using Thread,
Nest Detect is
able to operate for two years
on a small CR123 battery.
The Nest DL Lock is a connected
deadbolt for your door.
Like Nest Detect, it relies
only on Thread to communicate,
and operates as a
sleepy end device.
And by using Thread,
not only does
it last for years
on AA batteries,
but it can also respond to
remote lock-unlock commands
within seconds.
So it's very responsive.
And remote unlock is
an excellent example
of where you want secure
end-to-end communications.
That Thread supports
that by supporting IP.
Now, the Nest Guard is
a Thread border router
that connects both the Nest
Detect and Nest DL Lock.
It is a Linux-based
Thread border
router supporting
Wi-Fi and cellular,
in addition to Thread.
It uses wpandtund to expose
Thread as a standard network
interface to Linux-based
services and applications.
And it has a 12-hour
battery backup with cellular
to ensure that your Thread
network stays connected and can
communicate alarms outside your
home, even when power is lost
or Wi-Fi goes down.
And then we have
the Nest Connect.
It also serves as a
Thread border router,
connecting the Nest
Detect and Nest DL Lock.
Like the Nest Guard, it is a
battery-backed border router,
allowing it to maintain
Thread connectivity
even when power is lost or
even when Wi-Fi is down.
However, unlike the
Nest Guard, Nest Connect
is an RTOS class device, and
only supports Wi-Fi and Thread,
allowing us to really drive
the cost of that device down.
And with that, I'll
turn it over to Vaas.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY:
Thank you, Jonathan.
I've been at Nest
for over five years.
And I've enabled the 15.4
radio on several Nest products.
So for the rest of
this session, we're
going to talk about
how to take OpenThread
and other open source resources
available to quickly build
your IoT device.
With OpenThread being highly
portable, platform agnostic,
and IPv6-based, this opens up a
large number of options for us.
So we have several
system architectures,
operating systems, tool chains,
and radios to pick from.
So we're going to talk about
each of these categories
and figure out how to
make the right decisions
for your product, and what
the deciding factors are.
So let's start with the
system architecture.
We have three
models to pick from.
The first one is called System
on Chip, or the SoC model.
Here, we only have
one processor,
and both the application
and OpenThread
run on the single chip.
This model is typically
picked for a device that
has a simple function, and more
importantly for a device that
runs on battery power.
An example of this
device is Nest Detect,
which is the motion sensor
for doors and windows.
And the role of this device
on the Thread network
is a sleepy end device.
And it needs another fully
powered Thread router
to act as its parent.
There were a lot of
features added to OpenThread
and parameters provided
to get this device
to run on a single battery
for over two years.
So all of that is available
in OpenThread for everyone
to use as well.
Most radios typically come
with the single Thread chip,
but some today also have an
integrated Thread and BLE
radio.
So we have the option to
use more than one interface
for communication.
The next model is called
the NCP, or the Network Core
Processor architecture.
Here, the radio is its own chip
and we have a separate host
processor.
Now, this gives us a
lot more flexibility.
We can choose a host processor
that's a lot more capable.
And we get the
processing power to run
more complex applications.
We can even have a nice UI,
like a touchscreen display,
voice assistant.
You can have a Wi-Fi radio
to connect to the cloud,
and so on.
An example of this
device is the Nest Guard,
which is the security hub.
This has a keypad.
It has a speaker.
It has several radio sensors,
it has the Wi-Fi, BLE,
cellular radios, in addition
to the Thread radio.
The role of this device
is a Thread router,
and it's meant to operate as an
always-on fully powered device.
But with this NCP
model, we also have
the option of having
the host and the radio
sleep independently.
So when it's always on, both the
host and the radio are awake,
but when this device
loses external power,
it can run on battery
backup for up to 12 hours.
So at this time, the host
sends this information up
to the cloud, and it
immediately goes to sleep.
The radio, however, continues
to act as a Thread router,
and can wake up the
host when needed.
Another example of this model is
the more power-constrained Nest
Protect.
This is our smoke detector.
It's battery-powered.
And in this case, both
the host and the radio
are always asleep.
Now again, whenever
an event happens,
one can always
wake up the other.
The next model what we have is
the MAC and PHY architecture,
where, again, we have
two different processors
for the host and the radio.
But in this case, the OpenThread
core runs on the host processor
instead of on the radio.
And this model is great for
adding 15.4 Thread support
to existing products.
You can simply attach a 15.4
radio to an existing device,
and add support to it.
Since this model
is simple to use
and it has a quick
system integration,
it provides the
fastest time to market,
and it also offers the
lowest 15.4 component cost.
So depending on your application
and your product, what
your power constraints are,
what your UI looks like,
what are the radios
you have, you
can pick from one of these
three different architectures.
Next, we pick the
operating system.
OpenThread is platform agnostic.
So when we choose
the operating system,
we simply base it on the
complexity of your product.
So for something really simple
like actuator, or a sensor,
we can go with the bare
metal operating system.
For something a
little more complex,
we can go with the FreeRTOS.
And for much more
complex applications,
we can go with
Linux or the Linux
based operating system
like Android Things.
The Nest Detect uses FreeRTOS
for its operating system,
and [INAUDIBLE] for
its networking stack.
The Nest Guard uses Linux
for its operating system
on the host, and FreeRTOS
for the operating
system that runs in the radio.
So all these operating
systems, networking stocks,
and OpenThread are
all open source.
So we can quickly start adding
your application support
on top of this layer.
OpenThread is also
toolchain agnostic.
So it not only runs on these
several operating systems,
but you can also
compile it using
several well-known toolchains.
So we pick that basically
based on whatever
you're most comfortable with.
OpenThread also provides a
narrow platform abstraction
layer.
So all of these are great for
us to achieve very quick system
integration.
Next, we pick the radio.
There are several
radios available today
that can run OpenThread, and
we are not limited to this set.
It's easy to put
OpenThread to a new radio
if you want to use it.
Each radio here has a
different power memory and cost
associated with it.
And depending on the
exact features and memory,
each of these range
anywhere from $0.80 to $2.
So to determine
these requirements,
it's best to think of
the network as a whole.
So how many routers do
you have on the network?
How many sleepy end
devices do you have?
How many sleepy end devices need
to be supported on each router?
So what is the expected battery
life of your sleepy end device?
There is always a
trade-off between how often
the sleepy end device pulls
versus its battery life.
If you have to pull
too often, then
its going to drain
the battery quicker.
So first, we determine
this data pull rate.
And that on the other
side for the router
determines how long
each packet needs
to be queued for the
sleepy end device.
And the application
itself will determine
how large these packets
are, and how many
such packets need to be queued
for the sleepy end device.
Now multiply this by the
number of sleepy end devices
the router needs to support.
So that gives us the minimum
RAM requirement for this router.
So once we nail down the
network and memory requirements,
we can pick from
one of these radios.
So at this point, we can get
a couple of these development
boards, because
we made decisions
on the operating system,
toolchain, radio, and system
architecture.
And we can try out
our sample app.
So OpenThread provides a very
simple-to-use command line
interface.
So we can do a lot
of things to exercise
various features of Thread.
You can inform a
network, scan, join,
look at your neighbor
table entries,
look at your child
table, look at the signal
strength with each
neighbor that you have,
you can ping one device
to another in the network,
and so on.
And for a host in
NCP-based platform,
you can do the same thing
with our wpandtund tool.
And there are also several
code labs you can try out.
The code labs can either be
run on two physical devices--
these development
boards-- or you
can run it simply with
OpenThread in simulation mode.
So at this point, we can start
building your IoT product
by adding application support.
Now let's say you are
building an app that
has a light bulb controlled
by a remote switch.
You can start building this
by writing device drivers
for your product.
The radio drivers themselves
are provided by the radio
on platform vendors.
So that's something we
don't have to worry about.
And if your network only has
device-to-device communication,
we are good at this point.
However, if you want to send the
light's state updated to a web
app or your mobile
phone, we have
to add additional border
router and cloud support.
And for the application
itself, we can write our own
or we can leverage one
of several applications
that were written specifically
for connected devices.
Since the thread is IPv6-based,
we are not limited to this.
There are a large number
of options to choose from.
So this gives us everything
from application layer security,
connection communication
APIs, software download APIs,
and so on.
So we can take
advantage of this layer
and hook up our
application on top of this.
So the next piece of the
puzzle is addressing.
So how does your switch know
the address of the light
it's communicating to?
How does your light know the
address of the cloud service
that it needs to
send updates to?
Thread supports
standard IPv6 mechanisms
for local and
wide-area connectivity.
So all we're really doing is
building a normal IP network.
So everything from assigning,
discovering, to addressing
is exactly what we do for
a traditional IP network.
For Nest products, we
have picked a certain
naming and addressing schemes,
a cloud connectivity model,
and application layer security.
This layer is what
we call Weave.
And we recently open-sourced it.
It's called OpenWeave.
We also have a code
lab set up here at I/O
that everyone can try out
to understand what Weave is,
what it can do,
and how to use it.
So now that we've essentially
built our IoT device
by adding application
and addressing support,
our next task is to make the
network strong and reliable.
And OpenThread provides a number
of features and parameters
that help us with this.
First, OpenThread is
extremely configurable.
There is pretty much
everything that you want.
You can change from time
outs to number of children
that you want to support, how
large the buffer is, and so on.
You can turn on and off
features very easily
by putting in some defines
in a configuration file
to make the stack do
exactly what you want.
OpenThread also has
configurable logging.
And this logging is
configurable at runtime.
And that's the most
important thing.
So say you are debugging
a network issue.
And the network is working
great for several days,
and occasionally
there is an error.
It doesn't make sense
to have verbose logging
that entire time.
So what we could
do is at runtime,
when that error happens, you
can turn on extra logging just
doing that error condition.
OpenThread also has a
great set of counters.
We can see everything from the
number of packets transmitted,
received, dropped in every layer
from PHY to MAC to IP layers.
We can look at the transmit
data rate tracking, and so on.
So all of this helps us
with getting a deep insight
in the stack.
And we can debug really
easily with this.
OpenThread can
run in simulation.
So we can emulate an OpenThread
device using a POSIX process.
So if you want to test
a certain scenario
over a large number
of devices, we
can do so using the
OpenThread-Simulator.
Next, we have Toranj.
This is a Python-based
testing framework developed
by our colleague [INAUDIBLE].
It's very simple to use.
And you can see an
example of it right here.
So you can create
a number of nodes.
And what you can do is
you can tell the script
that I want you have only
these devices join me.
And I want to have these
devices blocked from joining me.
So with this, we are able
to create a complex network
topologies.
So you can run a certain
scenario over multiple hops,
or you can force a packet
to take a certain route
through the network.
Next, we have a Thread
topology monitor.
This is something
our team in Shanghai
put together for I/O.
It's actually live
and running in our sandbox.
And this is basically a live
interactive network map.
It gives you the device roles.
It tells you what
type of devices
are used, what radios
are used, and so on.
And this will soon be
open-sourced as well.
OpenThread supports standard
Wireshark traffic captures.
So we can get one of these
dev [? boards. ?] Just load
the standard NCP image--
it's a pre-NCP image--
and that's it.
We can start
sniffing immediately.
So the other feature is
that the radio can simply
be in monitor mode, where
it's just passive and acting
as an external
sniffer, or a device
that's part of
the network can be
put in a promiscuous mode where
it's a part of the network
and still capturing packets.
And this is again,
great debugging tool.
So if you're looking
for a lost packet,
you can pretty much have the
sniffer running on all devices
while it's on the network,
and look at their peak
apps later to determine
where the packet was dropped.
So as you can see,
all of these tools
were developed for OpenThread
to make it really easy to debug.
And as a result, we are able to
create a really stable network
and higher-quality products.
So at Nest, when we
started using OpenThread
in our products and testing it
more in real-world conditions,
we discovered several use cases.
And we started adding features
around each one of them.
So OpenThread is not only
Thread 1.1 compliant,
but it has a lot of
features, that in some cases,
are crucial for the success
of shipping products.
There are several
of these features.
And I've listed a bunch
of my favorites here.
So there is channel monitor
and channel manager.
So Thread operates
in 2.4 gigahertz,
the same frequency as Wi-Fi.
So to a wide interference, we
monitor all Thread channels,
we collect data
over days, and we
move to a clean channel
from time to time.
So that's the channel
monitor and channel manager.
There's another important
feature, jamming detection.
So we're able to detect when
our network is being jammed.
And we can alert
the application.
Another interesting feature
is the periodic parent search.
So when we first started working
on our Nest Garden and Nest
Detect, we made
the network really,
really strong between them.
So we tricked a
bunch of parameters
and made the
connection so strong
that when we deployed
them and we introduce
a new router in the middle,
like the Nest Connect,
the problem was this
device is sleepy.
And it was trying so hard
to maintain the connection
with the existing
parent that it could not
move to this better parent,
this potentially better parent.
So we introduced this feature
called Periodic Parent Search,
where every so often
the device will look
for a better parent and move.
However, we couldn't do this
too often, because every time we
were doing this, we were
keeping the receiver
on for eight seconds.
And that eats into
the battery life.
So we did some
computations and came up
with 10 hours as our number.
So every 10 hours,
our Nest Detect
will look for a better parent.
And even if the network
topology changes,
it will form the right parent.
And now we ran into
another use case.
So this device in the
middle, this new parent,
say it gets a software update.
It reboots.
And at this time,
the Nest Detect
immediately goes back to
the less appealing parent.
And now it doesn't
make sense for us
to wait a whole 10 hours.
So we detect an
involuntary detach,
and we check again in
10 minutes to go back
to our better parent.
So a lot of such
features were added.
And all of these are
practical use cases
that every product out
there will run into.
And Nest has already
gone through the process.
And we've added several
features that help everyone.
So in addition to those,
there were also really small
but high-impact improvements
that we've added.
So we talked about
this parent switch.
So each parent remembers the
information about a child
until a certain timeout.
So what happens is
when the child moves
to a different
parent, the old parent
does not know that it's gone.
So it continues to queue
packets for this child.
So we added another feature
to tell the old parent
that the child has moved on,
requesting it to remove it
from its child table.
So a lot of other changes
were added as well
to get a better sleep
current, and so on.
So to sum up, there were
a lot of useful tools
and a great number
of features that
are added to OpenThread
on top of Thread 1.1.
And I also want to point
out that OpenThread was not
designed just for with
Nest products in mind.
Our goal is to accelerate
the development
of connected devices everywhere.
So we not only made
it open source,
but we've also added several
features that Nest doesn't even
use, like DSAP, DNS, and co-op.
And these are very useful for
existing internet-based devices
to adopt Thread.
So please make use of these
tried and tested platforms
and the open source
platforms and tools.
And let's bring more of those
connected devices online.
So with that, let's
check out some demos.
What we have here is several
development boards all
running OpenThread.
So we have an Android
Things board here.
This is the IMX 70
[INAUDIBLE] board.
This is acting as a host.
It has an LCD screen, and it
has a speaker attached to it.
There is also the SiLabs
[INAUDIBLE] board.
This is acting as the NCP
for the Android Things.
We have a couple of Nordic
development boards here acting
as System on Chip.
One has a switch, and
the other one as a light.
We have a couple
of Raspberry Pis
here set up as border
routers, each of them
using a different radio.
One is using the TI
radio, another one
is using a Nordic dongle.
We have a SiLabs mighty
[INAUDIBLE] EFR32 development
board.
And also I have an NXP
dev board here that I'm
going to use as my sniffer.
So before we get into
the actual demo itself,
I want to show you some
tools and resources
and how to get to each
of these platforms.
So I'm going to plug in
the sniffer into my laptop.
First, let's go to
our GitHub page.
So this GitHub.com/openthread,
this is where we go.
So we have the code for
OpenThread, border router,
wpandtund, and [INAUDIBLE].
The [INAUDIBLE] is the
tool I'm going to use
to start my sniffer capture.
I may have to open a
different serial port here.
I think that looks
a bit better, maybe?
So well, while that's going in
the background, so that there,
that's the sniffer that's
running the standard NCP image,
starting to capture packets that
are flowing between these two
devices.
So I have a Nest Guard
and a Nest Detect here.
So you can see there
are data requests and IP
packets flowing back and forth.
And this is just standard
Wireshark that you see here.
So I'm going to log to this
device and show you some things
there.
So I'm logged into the device.
And I'm going to use
a wpandtund CDL, which
is the tool used by wpandtund.
It's the command line interface.
So we can do
wpandtund CDL status
to look at the status
of the network.
And we can do a
wpandtund CDL get.
And this prints
all the parameters
that we have associated
with this network.
And these are the counters
that I was talking about.
There's so many useful counters
to track various things.
And these are great
debugging tools.
So what I'm doing here is
just showing you the logs.
And I don't see any logs.
Got a typo there, sorry.
There.
So here, this is what
the logs look like.
And they are really great.
So you can see these are
just standard IP packets.
You can see these IP packets.
We can see data pulls
received from this device
to this device, and so on.
And I can also send a ping
from one device to another.
And that's just a
standard IP ping.
And if I go back to my
Wireshark, there it is.
So if you're familiar
with this too,
you'll immediately recognize
that these are just standard IP
pings and standard IP packets.
And the next thing I'm going to
show you is OpenThread on I/O.
This is the page that
we recommend going to.
And here, you have all the
information that you need here.
So you go to Platforms, and here
is all the development boards
that I have over there.
And you can click
on any of them,
and that will take you
to their GitHub page
where they tell you how
to built the samples,
how to load the code,
and run the example.
And if we go back, we can
see other operating systems.
We see the Linux-based
operating system.
We have Android Things, NCP
platforms, and the board
of router support.
So there's the Raspberry
Pi border router support.
And I've used this exact
example to replicate
the setup over there.
So I'm going to show
you how that works.
So that border router
is advertising an AP.
So here.
So first, we can
open up a web app.
I'm connected to that AP.
And I'm directly typing in
the IP address of the device.
And now I can directly start
controlling the network
from this web GUI.
So I can say, for
example, I can,
from the network from here--
so it's going.
And I can open up the
Thread Commissioning app.
So this can be downloaded
from Google Play.
And this will detect
the border router first.
There it found
the border router.
Now to add a device
to the network,
I'm simply going to
scan its QR code.
And when I do that, the QR
code contains information
about the serial ID of the
device and its pairing code.
And there, the Thread device
got added to the network.
And I can do the
same thing using
this sample I've programmed
in the Android Things board.
And there's a speaker attached.
So you might be able to hear
what it's doing as I'm typing.
So I can look at the
current network info.
- The device is offline.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: It
says device is offline.
I can scan.
- Scanning for networks.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY:
I find my network.
And I'm going to connect to it.
- Joining [INAUDIBLE].
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: And--
- The device is attached.
VAAS KRISHNAMURTHY: So there.
That was a simple app that
is also available on GitHub
that you can try out.
So now, I'm going to show
you the OpenWeave demo.
So this is similar to the one
that you have in the code labs.
It's just the result
of the code lab.
And we're going to go over that.
And what we have here
is a device configured
as a switch and another
device configured as a light.
And this pretty much is
just turning on the light.
And there's a lot of
mechanics that go into it.
So the light turned on,
and the light turns off.
So what this is doing is
sending a Wave packet, which
is encapsulated
in an IP message,
going over the Thread radio.
And the other thing that
also happens at this time
is we have a cloud service
running over there.
And every time I
change the state
of the light, that gets
updated in the cloud.
And that happens because this
information goes via Thread
to our border router.
And the border router is
connected to our Wi-Fi AP.
And it uploads it to the cloud.
So that concludes our demos.
[APPLAUSE]
We'd love to hear from you.
Please provide us some feedback
at our I/O scheduled place.
JONATHAN HUI: Yes.
So that's all we
have for you today.
Thank you very much for coming.
We really hope you
enjoyed this session.
I encourage you to go over
to our IoT sandbox, which
is just next door.
You can see more demos,
see more things happening,
meet the rest of the team.
And after tomorrow, you can
check out more information
at OpenThread.IO,
GitHub.com/openthread,
and go to
GoogleGroupsopenthread-users.
And thank you again
for joining us.
Have a great rest of Google I/O.
[MUSIC PLAYING]